alors comme daoud a été condamné il ya
deux semaines à verser 15 millions de
dollars de dommages et intérêts son
ancien compagnon johnny depp ou
diffamation johnny depp estime que le
jury lui a rendu sa vie après six années
d'enfer elle a été aperçue pour la
première fois depuis le verdict de ce
procès à l'aéroport et ce n'était pas en
classe éco dont l'actrice aurait été
paparazzi en train de monter dans un jet
privé pourtant il ya quelques semaines
son avocat a révélé qu'environ n'avait
pas les fonds nécessaires pour régler
une telle somme à johnny depp
une situation qui fait couler beaucoup
d'encre sur les réseaux sociaux je pense
qu'il est hypocrite de la part d'un
bureau heures de prétendre qu'elle n'a
pas d'argent pour payer johnny depp mais
qu'elle peut se permettre un sac à main
yves saint laurent un jet privé une
équipe de relations publiques et hama
nord de 22000 euros par mois bref vous
l'avez compris si l'opinion publique
n'était pas du côté d'hambourg hurd
l'actrice ne s'est pas fait de nouveaux
amis
ok alors oui normalement sa défense
c'est qu'elle a été tellement médiatisé
que ce procès qui était diffusé sur les
chaînes de télé chaîne youtube du monde
entier et elle a vraiment on avait une
mauvaise image auprès d'une certaine
partie de la population qu'elle ne peut
plus tard et de prendre l'avion même en
première classe donc ça c'est l'argument
de la défense ou du coup elle a joué à
la louer un jet pour toute la journée
les partis de new york elle est jusqu'à
washington allait rentrer en virginie la
wii s'est déroulée procès
l'argument ne tient pas parce que il y
avait quatre personnes un jet privé pour
une voyage presque d'agrément voiture
avec chauffeur etc on commence à dire la
presse américaine commence à sortir le
fait que serait dotée d'un patrimoine
immobilier et qu'en fait tu ne voudrais
pas payer donc là vraiment ça se
retourne totalement pour amber heard
déjà condamné mais là vraiment vilipendé
par la presse américaine on aura deux
spécialistes bien sûr
très bon dans un instant que
l'argent va à l'argent et l'argent va
aux amis donc bien sûr rétablir
plusieurs hypothèses ça se trouve c'est
un mec riche comme
mas connu donc ça se trouve c'est lui a
prêté un avion comme ça revient de la
publicité derrière
moi je pensais le patient moi je
n'attendais pas je ne la défend pas je
suis pro gianni letta mais on n'est pas
sûr que ce soit je suis frotté qui est
de donner cet argent c'est la viande est
bonne je
sais quoi à gauche m 60 un coin à
gulfstream 60 quelqu'un d'autre peut le
dire ce que l'on
ne dit pas des mots expliqué exprès des
avions transatlantiques qui peut aller
de new york à tokyo - la marimba et
pourquoi les paquets l'admet ce que
casas non lui on additionnait acheter il
en a plusieurs elle a comme on dit que
les bonnes relations
dans l'ascenseur
oui qu'ils soient pas ils sont proches
et donc apparemment il aurait déclaré
d'oseille pour voilà ce que c'est le
patron de tesla bien sûr entre
des hommes les plus riches dont
les voiles et c'est apparemment il sort
milliards de dollars 6 ans bail mais
sera en bail avec amber est derrière
vous les échos mais je connais très bien
non il est alors oui les riches
je veux dire à 200 milliards
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
nom
du projet peur d'être fluide ou sans
médias avaient révélé vous tous regardé
je perdais
sauvagine et total de 100 milliards ces
examens très regardée 200 me lasse pas
de ces lignes on 100 milliards garder
qu'est-ce qui ont ma vie r tout de suite
tu dis des plaines désolées firme à
10h15 non mais c'est vrai je vais pas la
même chose lacoste a dit non on n'y
croit pas aux
[Applaudissements]
problèmes
qu est ce qu il nous a balancé l'info
nulle part ailleurs de la viande entre 0
on a une info avant tout le monde et tu
te fous rires en fait le problème c'est
que toi tu l'aimés wittenheim et à
l'aider
tout ça pour dire que lambert ne sera
jamais à la rue parce qu'elle a des
mécènes milliardaire
soutenant même si elle a fait un truc de
catastrophique et que lille n'est pas si
riche en événements
moi j'aime des jetons qui la séparait
vous trouvez des périodes agréable
gentiment bord les jours c'est pas mon
délire les joues roses je suis demandé
leur art cependant elle s'est placée
c'est plus mon délire commun
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu crois que je vais faire le plus jeune
dompteur
et qu'est ce que vous seriez pas un gros
michto
tu as bien qu'on y voit là bas je ne
voyais pas être le mécène de hamburgers
mais c'est long mais c'est limite c'est
miguel a dû tourner les scènes midi
réunis dans la salle
elle demande que 5 millions $ et 5000 et
d'autres
non mais c'est vrai je connais pas cette
meuf la voix chez les potes de johnny
depp en plus mais moi j'ai jamais dis
pas que tesla qui joue à [ __ ] et je
peux aller dans l'espace donc ils vont
me fait chier non mais sans déconner ça
faut pas s'inquiéter pour des lots de
masques et très beau gosse
quoi vous roule électrique
roule électrique assez exactement toi tu
vas te tue bar où les dents